what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the character of Arry and
her unique and terrifying quirk well I
probably shouldn't use the words
breaking down in the context of Arry and
you will find out why in this video but
the point is that right here I will
explain everything you need to know
about areas of character and about her
incredible one-of-a-kind quirk I will
also explain her relevance to the wider
story of boku no hero and why she might
be an even more important character in
the future if you enjoy our boku no hero
videos and you want to see more please
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications the
way that YouTube works now if you don't
hit the bell and make sure to click off
the option for all notifications you are
definitely gonna miss a lot of our
videos they are not going to notify you
that's just the way it works feel free
to hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest boku no
hero news and updates and finally this
video will contain some spoilers for the
MHA manga so please proceed with caution
I will be covering ares backstory and a
specific nature of her quirk with that
said i will not be spoiling more of the
storyline than that and i will not be
spoiling how the overhaul arc ends so
with that in mind if you wish to proceed
please by all means go on but if you
don't want any spoilers whatsoever you
have been warned when we first meet ares
she is a six-year-old girl that for some
reason has found herself under the
influence of the ruthless villain chi
chi sake also known as overhaul at first
it seems strange to us that an
incredibly powerful villain like
overhaul a villain who can literally
destroy people with a single touch would
take such a keen interest in a helpless
little girl
but soon we learned the cruel truth of
why overhaul needs arey in order to
accomplish his criminal master plan area
is actually the granddaughter of the
former boss of the shia hasa Kai the
Yakuza criminal group also known as the
eight precepts of death which is
currently being
led by overhaul as I mentioned in my
previous video on overhaul chi-chi sake
was taken in as a child and practically
raised by this former Yakuza boss who
also happens to be Aerys grandfather
when arey was very young her quirk
activated suddenly without her realizing
what was happening and she accidentally
made her own father disappear in an
instant no one knew what exactly
happened but the assumption was that
Aerys quirk basically disintegrated her
father much like overhauls quirk has the
ability to disintegrate whatever he
touches now of course
arey did not hurt her father on purpose
she was just a small child who was
unable to control her newly manifested
quirk but because Aerys quirk did not
have any resemblance to either her
father's or her mother's quirk her
mother was scared of Aries ability she
thought that arey was cursed and so she
put the child into the care of her
father and Aries grandfather the guy who
also just happened to be a mob boss
since initially was believed that Aries
quirk was similar to overhaul the mob
boss put his apprentice overhaul in
charge of helping arey learn to control
her quirk Aries grandfather became ill
and he eventually became bedridden at
this point overhaul took control of the
eight precepts of death in his mentor's
place and that is when Aries hardships
truly began overhaul began conducting
cruel experiments on Airy in order to
determine the true nature of her quirk
and eventually he realized that Aries
quirk was not disintegrating people and
things like his own quirk instead Aries
quirk allowed her to rewind the body of
another person to a previous state so
for example if someone was injured arey
could rewind their body to a state
before they became injured therefore
healing them but the problem was that
area was still a child who was unable to
control her quirk in the case of her
father arey accidentally rewinded his
body to a state before he even existed
thereby essentially wiping her father
out of existence arey still could not
control her quirks so she could not
simply decide to use her quirk to a
certain extent and then just stop when
she wanted to because of this the
nature of her quirk made Airy very
dangerous to the people around her which
made her feel extremely guilty for his
part overhaul was fascinated by Aries
quirk now named rewind because of this
he decided to conduct experiments on
Airy including breaking down parts of
her body with his quirk and then
reassembling them after collecting her
blood this was of course a horrifyingly
painful process for Arry and it shows
what a truly vile and cruel person
overhall is this also explains why me
saying at the beginning that this video
is about breaking down Aries character
was probably a bad idea
through his cruel and despicable
experiments overhaul discovered that as
a result of her quirk Aries blood had
the power to take away the ability of
other individuals to use their quirks
this is because when their bodies come
into contact with Aries blood other
people's bodies are rewinded to a state
before their quirks developed and so
they suddenly become quick less overhaul
begins using Aries blood to create
special bullets that will take away
their targets ability to use their quirk
at first this effect is only temporary
and eventually the target will be able
to use their quirk once more but
overhauls plan is to figure out a way to
make the effects permanent which would
allow him to completely eradicate quirks
from the world if you've seen my
previous MH a video on overhaul you will
recall that he considers quirks to be a
disease a plague upon humanity he also
deeply resents the fact that the hero
society which arose as a result of
quirks has rendered the Yakuza a once
powerful and respected organization
virtually powerless overhaul is
determined to eliminate quirks in order
to eradicate the disease of quirks and
he is also determined to return the
Yakuza to its former glory
nevertheless the fact that overhaul is
willing to brutally torture an innocent
six-year-old child and experiment on her
just so he could accomplish his goal
shows just how truly psychopathic and
evil overhaul is even though Aerys
grandfather is the man who took over
halt in as a child and even though
overhaul owes everything he has to that
man and despite the fact that that same
man entrusted overhaul with the safety
of his grand
overhauls still decided to use an abuse
arey in such a cruel way the more we
think about it the more I have to
conclude that overhaul is truly the
sickest and most vile villain out of all
the villains in MHA probably even worse
than moon fish but now that we've talked
about Ares background and a bit about
her quirk we have to talk about her
character and how her dangerous quirk
and her tragic backstory affected her as
a person we do eventually learn more
about her quirk and the nature of its
powers and I will be covering that later
on in this video but first it is
important to flesh out Aries character
and her role in the wider story it is
important to note that Arry did not just
take over halls abuse without resisting
she tried to escape from him many times
but whenever she did overhaul managed to
find her and he would also brutally kill
anyone who tried to help her this made
Airy feel guilty she was afraid that if
she tried to escape overhaul would keep
hurting people because they are trying
to help her combine that with the
knowledge that she accidentally killed
her own father and you could imagine how
traumatized heir he became because of
all the tragic events in her life she is
basically stuck between a rock and a
hard place she doesn't want to keep
helping overhaul with his plans by
allowing him to keep experimenting on
her but she also doesn't want to cause
the death of innocent people by trying
to escape it is a terrible dilemma for
anyone to face let alone an innocent
six-year-old child Ares life is so sad
that when we first meet her she cannot
remember ever receiving any genuine
affection from another person for as
long as Airy could remember she has just
been used because of the unique nature
of her quirk she is perhaps the most
tragic character in the entire series
and you really can't help but feel
immense sympathy for her arrey is an
example of someone with an incredibly
powerful quirk but the power of her
quirk has been nothing but a curse to
her and the nature of her quirk is the
direct reason why he has been forced to
lead such a miserable life the reason
why this arc is one of my absolute
favorite arcs in the entire series is
the sharp dichotomy between overhaul and
airy to new characters who are
introduced for the first time during the
same arc
both of them have immensely powerful
queer
easily top five strongest works in my
hero academia and yet one of them is an
innocent and kind-hearted little girl
who doesn't want to hurt anyone and the
other one is a cruel and absolutely
ruthless killer who will stop at nothing
literally nothing to get what he wants
it really is an amazing setup for an
epic showdown between good and evil and
without going too much into spoiler
territory for those of you who are not
caught up this arc definitely delivers
an epic finale in terms of both action
and drama some additional things that we
learn about Aries quirk as the story
progresses includes the fact that once
she gets control of her quirk she could
be able to restore the quirks of those
individuals who lost their quirks as a
result of overhauls bullets we also know
that Aries quirk works only on living
creatures but not on inorganic objects
and we also know that her quirk rewind
is an accumulation type quirk
this means that area has to store power
over a certain amount of time before she
can effectively use her quirk this means
that even one day when she learns to
control her quirk she will still not be
able to use it to an unlimited degree
and even though she still hasn't learned
to control her power it is safe to
assume that when she does eventually
learn to control it area will become one
of the strongest characters in the
entire series her quirks ability to
rewind living beings has so many
potential uses both productive and
destructive and I can't wait to see how
Aries character and her quirk continue
to develop in the future I will also
mention that I predict that both Arry
and her quirk will become increasingly
important in the wider storyline of boku
no hero I mentioned earlier that Aries
quirk is a one-of-a-kind quirk that is
very different from the quirks that were
used by both her father and her mother
there is a school of thought within the
world of boku no hero that states that
with each passing generation quirks will
continue to get stronger and stronger as
different abilities continues to mix
with each other as they are passed down
from parents to their children
eventually quirks will become so
powerful that the children who inherit
them will not be able to control them
and this will result in chaos and the
unraveling of modern society this is
referred to as quirk singularity area
appears to be a clear early example of
this phenomenon a child whose quark
developed in a way that makes it far
different and far more powerful than the
quirks of her parents and in fact her
quark is so powerful that she cannot
control it and this puts the people
around her in danger areas likely just
the beginning of this phenomenon a
harbinger of things to come but at the
same time once Airy does learn to
control her quark she may end up playing
a pivotal role in the rest of the story
her quark may allow her not only to
rewind the effects of injuries and
illnesses and the effects of overhauls
quark canceling devices but also to stop
overpowered future quirks from doing
damage to society she could potentially
do this by rewinding their user to a
state before the quark manifested at
least until the user is able to control
it if that is the case then ironically
Airy one of the first examples of the
dangers of quark singularity could end
up saving society from the negative
effects of that same quark singularity
whenever a small child manifests some
really dangerous quirk that they cannot
control arrey would go there rewind the
child back to before the perk manifested
and allow the child to get older before
they could actually start using the
quark once they learn to control it but
those are just my own thoughts let me
know what you guys think how strong does
Ares quark have the potential to become
and what are some creative uses of her
quark that haven't been revealed in the
story so far also what do you think of
airy as a character and how big of a
dick is overhaul feel free to hit me up
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more MHA content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications remember
that you have to turn on all
notifications otherwise YouTube will
bury our videos and you will not see
them you can also follow me on twitter
and instagram at anime on / or for all
the latest MHA news and updates and we
also share our videos there so if you
don't get notified on youtube you will
still see our videos right there on
Twitter and Instagram
I want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime out pro patrons who make
videos like this one possible special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell dress on he'll cruise Steelers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat a karate
GN Anatoly Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel and
alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata Allen
Adham
Merrimack makoto-kun and ya boys Seth if
you enjoy our videos and you think that
they add some value to your life
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our page and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]